[Musique]
la grève ne peut pas durer pendant les
vacances de noël
ce gouvernement en entretenant le flou
sur la réforme en expliquant tout et son
contraire en expliquant pas comment il
ce qui va le financer se retrouve à
jouer l'opinion en expliquant que
regarder ces méchants grévistes qui vont
vous empêchez vous d'aller voir vos
enfants vos petits enfants de passer
noël en famille et ce clash de l'opinion
ne va pas dans le sens du débat sur le
coeur de la réforme mais sur est-ce que
la grève est justifiée ou pas il y en a
cgt elles doivent faire preuve un peu
d'humanité
voilà c'est ça être quand même une bonne
chose et de se dire qu'il ya plein de
français qui partagent ou pas leurs
opinions leurs combats qu'importe la
réalité passé là c'est qu' une période
qui doit être sacré et période sacrée
faut les respecter et noël c'est une
période sacrée c'est la réunion des
familles c'est beaucoup de choses comme
cela je vais pas vous l'expliquer chacun
le comprend très bien ce qu'il se doit
être suspendu il ya beaucoup de cynisme
dans cette présentation de réforme de
retraite d'abord le faire quinze jours
avant noël uniquement pour bach gagner
la bataille de l'opinion et pour
retourner l'opinion à son avantage c'est
la république avec monsieur macron des
amateurs ou des branquignols
on ne sait plus qui aujourd'hui parmi
les auditeurs parmi nos concitoyens est
capable d'expliquer cette réforme des
retraites
à force d'être illisible à force d'être
injuste à force d'être arrogant et bien
on crise on divise on fragmente la
société français le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que la manière dont le
gouvernement a géré les choses amène à
cette situation là il serait menacé si
tu es sûr là parce qu'il ya eu des
périodes de cacophonie totale c'est que
le chiffre d'affaires des commerçants
est multiplié par 2 par 3 voire par cinq
et donc il ya un impact économique
majeur il ya une responsabilité du
gouvernement là dessus parce que c'est
lui qui est maître du calendrier le
gouvernement présente sa réforme
quelques jours avant noël faut admettre
que
et donne aussi des bâtons pour se faire
battre beaucoup de familles ne vont pas
pouvoir se retrouver à noël ça c'est le
pire de tout bien sûr noël c'est quelque
chose de sacré pour tout le monde
dans une france déjà extrêmement perdu à
l'aller à qui allez allez les nerfs à
fleur de peau qui est à bout de nerfs
sera montré qu'il ya plus aucune période
qui est sacré même des périodes où on
pense plutôt à sa famille qu'autre chose
le droit de grève oui le droit de
bloquer les français est dans merde et
tout le monde non
[Musique]